kofi 19 has come through and completely
decimated and put on pause the bar and
restaurant industry at about eat no get
people out of work and bar and
restaurant owners struggling to come up
with new ways to possibly stay in
business
I'm Jacob Greer I work in the barn
hospitality business and I'm also a
freelance writer right for a reason
magazine as well as up there public
policy outlets
talking to other people in the industry
talking to bartenders they want two
things one they want to go back to work
but they also want to stay safe and it's
really hard to do both at the same time
if the only option is for people to come
into a bar or restaurant and to gather
inside we're seeing it's just a recipe
for spreading the virus so we don't want
to end up in a cycle of reopening and
then reclosing constantly which we're
seeing right now if you'd like to find
something that's more stable talking to
people in my industry the number one
item on their wish list is to be free to
sell cocktails to go they want to be
able to package a drink up to go
alongside their food or even by itself
for a customer to take home and drink
there
now the other quick ideas would be to
expand outdoor spaces for drinking which
could be through closing sidewalks
putting on tables even closing down and
tige streets and creating public social
plazas or if you want to go all the way
there eliminating open container laws
entirely so it's no longer a crime to
have a drink outside so in much of the
world especially in Asia and other parts
of Europe
it's not against the law it's not a
crime to be outside drinking and that
was the case in the United States as
well from most of our history it was not
a crime simply to drink in public it was
a crime to be drunk in public and that's
a key distinction in the 1970s there
became this push to make the law less
discretionary more objective and the way
they did that was to say the act of
drinking itself is now the crime and
that highly constrained where people
could drink when we think of open
containers we think of party atmospheres
like Las Vegas or Bourbon Street in New
Orleans but there's also a lot more
relaxed places that have varying degrees
of open container permission like say
Hood River in Oregon or Sonoma in
California it doesn't have to be a party
atmosphere especially if you don't force
everyone into one narrow space could be
just allowing people to have a drink in
the park to have a picnic to walk around
their neighborhood with a drink in hand
prohibition happened in 1920 and
contrary to popular image of the fun
speakeasy with great cocktails what
actually happened was we destroyed our
cocktail culture in the United States
through that period and we didn't really
recover until the early 2000s up until
now and all of this has been hugely hit
by the the shutdown right now I view
these laws about allowing us to do
cocktails to go and expanding outdoor
spaces as much about damage control as
anything else and to prevent this from
being completely erased and giving it
some chance to survive
[Music]
you